would you rather have earthworms for
eyebrows or clams for ears Kelly's
really thinking about it you guys I need
you to see her face right oh hi I'm
heaven from another round and I'm here
with the multi-talented miss Kelly
Rowland mrs. Kelly Rowland this is Kelly
Rowland weathers weatherspoon we're
about to do some pewpewpew rapid-fire
questions and I'm so excited to be
talking with you Kelly are you ready for
this jelly no I'm so sorry I had to do
it I could not not do it jelly
hey random question number one yes do
you immediately change into super soft
clothes when you get home yes like is it
like immediately I'm taking my pants off
situation yes mhm I love nice pajamas oh
yes I will buy pajamas
okay so fastest Oh pajamas is there a TV
theme song you ever find yourself
singing well moving on up okay we have
some silly would you rather question
okay would you rather have earthworms
for eyebrows or clams for ears Kelly's
really thinking about it you guys I need
you to see her face right she's deep in
thought I think I would rather have
earthworms forever okay I like I like
the kevro
fake fuzzy yes I'm glad it's
quote-unquote in right now but like
every brown girl was like hey where we
all at yeah yeah like a few years ago
yes rude you like I'm on it would you
rather have your deepest darkest secrets
come out every time you fart or have
spaghetti for pubes again decent thought
oh goody for few wait that was so easy
tell me about that spaghetti for pubes
cuz you know it was spaghetti you can
just like take them off I don't want
like the texture and I feel like they
could get kind of weird
no damp wet so josh is just like here
you can take them home
what are some of the songs I remind you
of your childhood songs that remind me
of my childhood
Jenny Jackson's when I think a few um to
Whitney Houston's on your baby tonight
that was actually a song that I
auditioned to to be in the group really
yes
oh my god Michael Jackson's keeping in
the closet which is wearing on Naomi
with all of that hair yeah and I
actually used to put on my mama scarves
do you know to me I can't absolutely I'm
in there oh good god ah love do you ever
feel nostalgic when you feel missed all
took for when I lived at home with my
mama
really yes because I didn't have much of
a care Nora you know when you're a kid
you just have that moment to where it's
just innocence hmm and I think that more
people should embrace innocence
mmm operate off of kindness a kind love
agape love no we don't do much of that
these days that was so beautifully put
yes sorry I love that I didn't mean to
you not apologize yeah I are getting
light bulb
[Music]